I think the light sensor would be the best answer.
Cause then you would know that it's dark and your
users asleep. But also the accelerometer and the gyroscope, would
tell you that your user hasn't moved so their sleeping.
>> Yeah, and you would think that this is an isolated problem, but
it's not. In fact it's such a huge issue for users, that there
exists entire category application. Agent being one of them. Which actually is a
stand alone app, which silences your
phone. So that other applications won't disturb
you in the middle of the night, with information you don't really want.
>> Apps like Trigger take into account
these triggers like light and accelerometer. And
they know that if you're sleeping or
you're not moving, they'll silence your whole phone.
But if you're building an application that
provides sports updates. You should take advantage of
these sensors within the application, and deliver
the notification when you know the user's awake.